this initiative goes further than any
other initiative anywhere in the world
when it comes to marijuana legalization
hi I'm Zack Weiss Muller for Reason TV
here with Lyn Lyman California State
Director for the drug policy Alliance
and proponent of prop 64 which would
legalize commercial marijuana sales in
California so if you have anything you
want to know about marijuana
legalization start posting in the
comments section of this video right now
so we've seen commercial legalization in
several states now Colorado Washington
Oregon Alaska something resembling it in
Washington DC although because it's a
federal district we hasn't really been
implemented what does it mean for the
country if California jumps on that
bandwagon and legalizes it this
initiative goes further than any other
initiative anywhere in the world when it
comes to marijuana legalization we're
really setting a new floor for what
marijuana legalization should include
this is not just about people being able
to smoke their weed this is not about
people being able to make their money
you know those things will happen in the
process but this is about rectifying
decades of failed war on drugs that has
really been driven by marijuana offenses
if you look at drug arrests and so to
address that we've taken some stats in
this initiative that that we see as
reparative justice the second thing that
makes a significant for the country is
the size of California we will nearly
double the number of people who are
living in a jurisdiction that doesn't
have marijuana prohibition through this
initiative and so we see California
particularly there's four other states
as well and if all five of us were to
pass marijuana legalization this year it
could really be the tipping point to end
prohibition federally since California
last tried this with prop 19 and failed
at it there's been an inflection point
in public opinion where we suddenly see
the majority of public is in favor of
marijuana legalization in a strange way
the biggest obstacle seems like it might
be complacency people see that medical
marijuana is legal here
it's pretty easy to get
medical marijuana for just about anybody
so people think why bother
marijuana is only illegal for white
people in California practically when
you look at how the law is being applied
if you are white than you and you are 21
and over you can pretty much use
marijuana without any sort of criminal
justice involvement that is not true for
african-americans in California or even
for Latinos african-americans are four
times more likely to get stopped for
marijuana Latinos two times more likely
despite the fact that white people use
in sell marijuana at slightly higher
rates than black and Latinos in
California if California were to pass
this legalization of commercial sales of
marijuana what would you expect would
happen in terms of the prison population
the jail population do you have any idea
my guesstimate is it's going to be under
10,000 people who are currently in jail
who will now be eligible for having
their sentence reduced much like
happened under Prop 47 and this is also
applicable retro actively so to anybody
who has a marijuana offense on their
record going back five ten fifty years
will be eligible to have the record
cleared and I think that could be having
gone through this with Prop 47 where in
LA County alone we had 800,000 people
eligible for Prop 47 record change I'm
guessing that we're going to be at about
half a million at least statewide for
the marijuana change so hundreds of
thousands of Californians will be able
to have the record cleared and I'm
thinking it's going to be you know
between five and ten thousand will be
able to petition to get released from
jail but I think then people are maybe
thinking well there's not really many
people that are being punished just for
marijuana but you mentioned that it is
kind of the foundation of the drug war
could you expound on that a little bit
yeah well when you look at mass
incarceration and how we got where we
are for for those of your viewers who
may not know we have 5% of the world's
population and 25% of the world's
prisoners and what has got us here was
the war on drugs and our drug laws so
the biggest sort of feeder is a
is drug arrests about 1.2 to 1.5 million
drug-related arrests a year half of
those are marijuana only offenses we're
seeing that law enforcement has just
really not eased up and generating seven
hundred eight hundred thousand arrests
in this country every year and
continuing to keep our our prisons and
our jails which is where a lot of these
folks are going even in other states
over fall what has California in
crafting this initiative prop 64 learned
from what these other states have done
right and done wrong the governor
recently assigned into law medical
marijuana regulation and so for the most
part Prop 64 just builds on the
bureaucratic structure I'll call it
there's a new Bureau the Bureau of
marijuana control it's inside the
Department of Consumer Affairs kind of
like the ABC has always been for liquor
retailers they will be for cannabis
retailers and cultivators all of the
licenses so so one of the things we
learned was be intentional arrests drop
drastically we're all marijuana related
arrests dropped drastically after
legalization in every jurisdiction the
the racial discrimination and that
disparity continues to exist just at
lower numbers and so that was one of the
the reasons it was so important to
protect kids from the criminal justice
system with this initiative and I'd like
to dig a little bit more into the
details of the regulation in a second
but well first we'll turn to our
questions we've got a couple pulled up
from Facebook
Josh Kelly asks how can we convince
long-standing anti marijuana citizens
that marijuana is a good thing well I
don't know if I would ask anybody who
believes that too to change their mind
and believe that marijuana is a good
thing what I would ask that person is is
marijuana legalization better than what
we have today so reducing the numbers of
people who go into the criminal justice
system for marijuana and a product
that's safer for consumers regulated by
public health and the people who do that
isn't that a better option even if you
don't like marijuana or you think it's a
bad thing
Robert Rosales says why can't 18
year-olds get prescription marijuana
when 10 year olds can get oxycontin
well actually prop 64 does not affect
prop 215 which is The Compassionate Use
Act which allowed you know medicinal
marijuana for patients so we don't touch
that prop 215 applies to 18 and over
it's interesting the politics of medical
marijuana and commercial marijuana
because we saw last time during prop 19
a strange anti marijuana force arose in
Northern California with the growers the
small family farms growing marijuana
were afraid they were going to get
crushed by commercialization so they
actually came out against commercial
legalization what has prop 64 done to
address that and kind of bring them into
the fold one of the big pieces that are
that we try to be responsive to that
concern is a five-year ban on large
licenses so for the first five years no
large licenses will be given out and
that's 22,000 square feet or above we
also wrote into the licensing regime
that the regulating agency has to
consider whether handing out this
particular license to this particular
business would lead to the creation of a
monopoly the licensing is where we get
into the areas of concern for me from a
libertarian perspective where there's
kind of a self-conscious approach to
approach it like the wine industry or
beer where you have the tiered system so
you know you can get a license to be a
distributor or a grower or a retail
seller but it may be impossible to hold
all of those licenses so there's not
what they call vertical integration not
under Prop 64 we put a special license
type license type number 19 which is
called the micro license so for small
shops you can get a micro license fully
vertically integrated 10,000 square feet
or less and what's the rationale for
this kind of tiered licensing once they
get bigger the licensing we flip for the
most part replicated what the governor
and the legislature passed for med
last year we did add the micro license
we added the five-year ban so we did you
know we did a few little improvements
around the edges to protect the growers
and the small business people in terms
of personal use and growing in your own
home that's treated as a totally
separate thing yeah that's back to
personal use so you can have up to an
ounce of flower marihuana flower on you
up to 8 grams of concentrate or up to
six plants at home let's say we have
another question from Matt vest what
would you say to people who believe that
cannabis is a gateway drug that it's not
you just can't find any hard scientific
evidence behind that theory what we do
see is that people who end up having
problematic drug use at some time you
know later in their life probably we're
doing everything they could at a really
young age meaning alcohol tobacco
marijuana whatever was in their families
you know medicine cabinet
there is no causation between using
marijuana and ending up with problematic
drug use Jeff Hamilton asks doesn't
over-regulation of marijuana
tend to undercut the gains made by
decriminalization by continuing to make
the black-market attractive for buyers
and sellers it's particularly a
challenge in California that the other
states have not had because in
California because of medical marijuana
legalization in 1996 we've had a mihrab
we have a 20 year old marijuana industry
most of these states didn't so we have
to transition our underground market
into a legal market on the issue of
taxation is related to this so if you
taxed too high people will stay in the
underground illicit market so but but
you have to tax and so we've seen that
play out I believe in Oregon a little
bit where the taxes were he was washing
Washington where the taxes on recreation
were so high that everybody stayed in
the medical market which wasn't being
taxed at all so they had to you know
they had to adjust and we may have to
adjust as well if we just had the one
excise tax which is 15% under this
initiative at retail it would be fine
but counties and cities have the
authority to add additional taxes on so
if we're getting up to 3035
cent tax that's when yeah people are
going to stay in the illicit underground
market and we're trying to begin now to
work with cities and counties to say
don't go crazy I know you need money for
everything don't go crazy start low
maria Emmons
asks has anyone overdosed on marijuana
no but that doesn't mean that marijuana
isn't or can't be dangerous
right it is a psychoactive substance no
doubt about it and consuming too much
consuming it in the wrong space
consuming it on top of any sort of
mental health or physical issues you may
have I think that what we have to do is
provide what would I call reality based
drug education to young people into
adults like the reality [ __ ] no it is
not going to kill you can it be
dangerous yes here's why don't mix it
with alcohol you know don't take it
before you drive if you're doing edibles
start small start with just a few grams
I'll be more in doubt don't be bearing
down right like keep a journal of how
much you took and how it made you
feeling it's gonna take 60 to 90 minutes
so wait you're 90 minute you know so
that's what we need to do not tell
people Marilyn's going to kill you
and we had a question from cash Foley
who asks does going further than
anywhere else in the world put this
initiative at risk
well yes and this is why people can't be
complacent and they can't stay at home
and they can't say uh it's practically
legal who needs to vote on it or you
know the line was too long law
enforcement who is our primary opponents
are coming on hard they have some some
kind of real big scare tactics up their
sleeve and if they raise the money then
it's going to be a tough race some of
the tactics I've heard or I guess the
talking points from that side is it's
very focused on the protecting the
children type of argument and you
address that a little bit at the
beginning in terms of the labeling and
us you know allowed to sell it in your
schools what about the argument that
legalizing something sends the message
to children that it's okay and therefore
more kids are going to then experiment
with marijuana before they should I
don't think it has any merit I'm a
mother of a 12 year old and no she
cannot talk to my alcohol no she cannot
touch my marijuana
so I think it's pretty easy for parents
to be clear about something maybe legal
but it's not safe for children and/or
okay for children or even acceptable for
children so I think that that's that's
kind of a dog whistle the whole watch
out for the kids thing I think is just
you know the cops trying to hide behind
the children and this is an interesting
question from Tim Hess does California
have a plan to store the revenue from
weed sales which has led to problems in
Colorado and just for our so our
audience knows what he means Colorado
took in so much money from commercial
marijuana sales that they had a budget
surplus and they had no law in place
with what to do with all the extra cash
so does California have a plan if that
should happen well I think the
California Legislature and the
government would be so happy if that
happened but I don't expect that to
happen one of the things we did learn
from Colorado is to be more prescriptive
with the revenue allocation so we are
very prescriptive there's a number of
funds I could run through them if you
want to give us a taste of where it's
going so at full implementation which
will take a few years right verax the
revenue is expected to be about 1
billion that's an estimate from the
nonpartisan Legislative Analyst's Office
so of that billion there's some pieces
off the top 10 million goes to the UC
system for research on the impact of
legalization 3 million goes to
California Highway Patrol to do research
on driving under the influence the most
exciting piece that comes off the top is
is this reparative justice piece which
we call the community reinvestment fund
it's 50 million dollars a year that will
go into those communities that have been
hit the hardest by the war on drugs and
provide them with services legal
services education economic
opportunities financing support etc the
rest is split in percentages three ways
60% of the remaining so we're talking
500 million potentially will go to youth
drug education treatment and prevention
20 percent goes to the environment and
that is for environmental remediation
and restoration there's there's been a
lot of damage from illegal grows
particularly up north and then 20
percent goes back to the low
government and the local government can
pretty much do you know what they want
with it if a local government bans
commercial sales they will not get their
20% the big outstanding question mark
here is kind of what is the federal
government going to do if the largest
state in the Union legalizes commercial
marijuana we saw under the Obama
administration at least at the beginning
of that administration there's actually
a ramp up of raids on medical marijuana
clinics who knows what a trump
administration would do on this issue
and Clinton administration you know
she's not even ostensibly as liberal as
Obama so what do you expect might happen
at the federal level if this passes
marijuana laws in states are sort of
guided by what's called the Cole memo
the Cole memo essentially said this came
out of Obama's Department of Justice
several years back and it said we aren't
going to interfere with the states we
you know states who want to experiment
with marijuana laws we're going to stay
out if you follow these eight or ten
guidelines so obviously in every state
where we've legalized we have followed
the guidelines to keep the feds out but
the Cole memo becomes no longer the
ruling sort of document with a new
presidency the other issue is funding
for the DEA and the US Attorney's to
prosecute
marijuana's in the States so there was
the rollback or amendment our
congressman from Orange County Dana
Rohrabacher with a number of other
California congressmen on both sides of
the aisle passed legislation a year or
two ago that said the federal government
can't use federal money to interfere in
another states in in a state's marijuana
laws so that would actually be changed
by Congress the Cole memo could just be
changed by the president but but them to
refund on the federal government you
know sticking their hands into our
marijuana laws would take I believe a
new a new vote in Congress what do you
see in the next five or ten years do you
think you know marijuana legalization is
going to sweep the nation are we going
to start talking about other drugs being
legalized
what do you expect might happen well I
do see this as a tipping point for
marijuana and I do think marijuana
legalization will sweep the nation and
eventually will federal prohibition will
be ended I see that on a five to ten
year track but marijuana legalization is
really only just the first step so my
organization drug policy Alliance we
will be moving towards really advancing
all drug decriminalization so what we
call the Portugal model where nobody can
get arrested for using drugs ever yeah I
mean you can still get citations and you
can be called to do this community
service or that but you cannot get
arrested for using drugs in the country
of Portugal and what have they seen they
implemented this in 2001 and in those
years since then they have seen of
course incarceration and arrests have
gone down but drug treatment has gone up
and staying in drug treatment and youth
use has gone down and overdoses have
gone way down so we really see marijuana
as maybe the low-hanging fruit of this
battle and this is all very much tied
into mass criminalization so taking away
these tools for a law enforcement to
overly harass and criminalize people for
you know what they're putting in their
bodies when Lyman thank you for talking
to us it's good to see you again sex for
reason TV I'm Zack Weiss night is a pro
edition has only created you know crime
violence and the separation and
destruction of families it's time to end
prohibition to Gateway to crime it's a
gateway to addiction could make the same
claims about alcohol because it is such
a popular drug relation again well you
can correlate it any way you want
you